pues inicialmente familiares estaban a
la salida de la llegada Internacional
del aeropuerto de use para poderlos
abrazar poder compartir con ellos
después de muchos meses incluso años
estas personas han estado pues detenidas
allá en Nicaragua Pero salió un oficial
del departamento de estado a comunicarle
a todas las personas que estaban
esperando incluso los medios de
comunicación que estos prisioneros
llegaban a Washington pero iban a ser
trasladados directamente al hotel en
este momento en el que estamos el hotel
westing y ellos han sido pues eh han
sido entrados al hotel por unas puertas
traseras del Hotel directamente a un
salón donde les están dando la
bienvenida allá en ese salón acá a mis
espaldas pues se están reuniendo los
familiares de estos prisioneros
nicaragüenses con Pues los que llegaron
este vuelo cerca de 222 prisioneros que
llegaron hay muchos sin embargo que no
tiene familiares para recibirlos acá en
Washington y se quedarán acá en este
hotel según algunas Fuentes con las que
hablamos y familiares que estaban en el
aeropuerto nos dicen que pues el
departamento de estado habilitado este
hotel incluso ocho semanas Se podrían
quedar estas personas para después ser
trasladadas a diferentes estados del
país la diáspora de nicaragüense ha
preparado en varias ciudades de Estados
Unidos precisamente lugares donde pueden
llegar estos prisioneros que no tienen
personas conocidas acá que legalmente no
tienen papeles y que estarían entonces
esperando en estos lugares el trámite
legal que está ofreciendo el gobierno
estadounidense para empezar una vida
legal en los próximos dos años acá con
razones humanitarias y así es como
Argumenta el departamento de estado y el
gobierno estadounidense la justificación
para recibir a estos 222 prisioneros que
ya están en el suelo estadounidense ya
están por grupos empezando a llegar a
este hotel y se quedarán los próximos
días Acá hay que Resaltar que aunque
blinquen el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos haya dicho que esto
camino para un futuro diálogo Estados
Unidos sigue en pie con sus sanciones al
gobierno de Daniel Ortega otro detalle
que conocimos también es que a la
llegada estos prisioneros pasaron
también sus pruebas de covid antes de
poder ser trasladados a este hotel